Speaker 1: Hey, David, how could Republicans
convince young people to start voting for
them?
Yeah, so there's still this really big imbalance
in the 2020 US election.
Presidential, 60 percent of voters, eighteen
to twenty nine voted for Joe Biden, 60 percent.
Only 36 percent voted for Donald Trump.
I think a lot of this is sort of a culture
war issue related.
And I'll explain it to you in this way.
The Republican Party historically has had
their sort of more religious and cultural
issues and then their policy platforms, the
policy platform of low taxes and low regulation.
It's not really appealing to young people.
And that is not a draw for young people to
the Republican Party.
When the country was more religious, stuff
like being against gay marriage and being
against abortion, maybe did more to pull some
young people in to the Republican Party.
But over time, we are seeing that even so-called
conservative young people tend to have significantly
more liberal views when it comes to economic
issues than they did 15 or 20 years ago.
The Occupy Wall Street movement was a part
of that, and other things have affected that.
They are increasingly less religious.
So like gay marriage, abortion are not big
issues for most young people.
So what does the Republican have to offer
them?
Maybe the new culture war issues could potentially
work.
So, for example, if somebody like Madison
Cawthorn, a young Republican elected official
from North Carolina, not South Carolina, as
I misstated last week, if Madison Cawthorn
can get young people really fixated on the
new cultural issues, which include, you know,
the platforming and free speech and censorship,
cancel culture and that type of thing, maybe
that's a way that the Republican Party could
capture more of the young vote.
That's a possibility.
The problem, as I see it, is that the Republican
Party on policy doesn't really have much right
now other than opposed Democrats cut welfare
programs and cut taxes.
They are against the Affordable Care Act,
but they don't really have a solution.
And young people are probably aware that if
ACA goes, if I'm under twenty six, I may not
be able to stay on my parent's insurance.
So there's no interesting policy ideas.
And so as interesting as the idea of we're
going to fight cancer culture and we're going
to fight against policing of speech and platforming
and all the stuff that might be interesting
to some young people and might pull them towards
the Republican Party if they care at all about
policy, there's going to be nothing there.
So I think that unless there's a wholesale
change within the Republican Party, they're
going to keep hemorrhaging young voters.
Now, that being said, still, given how ridiculous
Republican policy has been towards anything
that young people would care about.
It's shocking they still got 36 Trump, Trump
still got 36 percent of the 18 to 29 nine
vote doing everything wrong, they still got
thirty six percent of the vote.
So this is one of those things where on the
one hand, the Republican Party is doing everything
wrong to try to appeal to young people.
And the things I think could help them appeal
to more young people are not things they seem
interested in doing.
So that seems terrible.
Spells disaster.
But yet, on the other hand, they still got
36 percent of the 18 to 29 vote.
So only some small tweaks could probably make
them quite competitive or at least closer
to competitive among that group.
Give me your sense of whether there is a way
to maintain something that is the modern Republican
ideology that would appeal to young people.
I'm not really sure that there is.